es una habitación pequeña seguridad
extrema y llena de tesoros ocultos
aquí es donde guardamos todas las obras
de arte incautadas
hay alrededor de un centenar de
antigüedades que fueron robadas o
saqueadas de egipto
presumo
ay
una parte está almacenada en las
estanterías y el resto lo guardamos en
este baúl en términos de cantidades una
incautación masiva hay que esperar al
peritaje para ver cuánto vale
egipto siria libia mira todos han sido
saqueados en los últimos años con
cientos de obras de arte robadas de las
zonas arqueológicas y desde que estalló
la pandemia los expertos afirman que se
ha triplicado el número de grupos en las
redes sociales dedicados a vender el
arte saqueado
[Música]
los saqueadores incluso han subido
vídeos de ellos mismos exhibiendo las
obras en este videoclip grabado en alepo
se preparan para extraer un mosaico de
un sitio
[Música]
este arqueólogo ha encontrado una
tablilla robada grabada con escritura
cuneiforme y que está a la venta en
internet
las tablillas vienen de irak sirias
zonas de guerra el arte saqueado puede
por supuesto financiar el terrorismo y
es como llevarse la historia de un país
ilegal
[Música]
pero el tráfico también se las arregla
para llegar a los mercados legítimos
morgan bélgica mil blogs ya llevan años
rastreando las ventas de obras de arte
han elaborado un mapa de todas las que
fueron saqueadas o robadas y dicen que
muchas obras acaban en casas de subastas
bien establecidas
[Música]
y este retrato fue vendido por bonanza
en 2015 el que dijeron pertenecía a un
tal señor ese de zúrich en los años 90
pero tenemos fotos tomadas por los
saqueadores son de 2013-2014 y fueron
publicadas en las redes sociales para
intentar vender la obra es probable que
el retrato provenga de una tumba
por el momento
la casa de subastas ha negado estas
acusaciones diciendo que ellos
comprueban los antecedentes de cada obra
que reciben sin embargo las fotos siguen
siendo cruciales para presentar una
denuncia ante la policía para que pueda
abrirse una investigación
y encontrar las fotografías es una
batalla si no podemos conseguir ninguna
sólo podemos sospechar que fueron
robados algunas personas en libia ponen
su vida en riesgo tratando de encontrar
esas fotos futuro
[Música]
qué tan estrictas son las casas de
subastas a la hora de rastrear el arte
que venden una venta en mónaco nos llamó
la atención
el catálogo de la subasta dice que este
busto fue vendido por christie's en
nueva york' en 2007 pero las autoridades
libias creen que pudo haber sido
encontrado en una excavación ilegal
aunque efectivamente estuvo a la venta
en christie's no encontró comprador y se
expuso en barcelona- en 2015
en la actualidad el galerista está
siendo investigado por las autoridades
españolas por posible financiación del
terrorismo nos reunimos con el director
de la casa de subastas en mónaco donde
fue vendido recientemente
[Música]
es bastante sorprendente que esta obra
de arte haya podido encontrarse en una
excavación ilegal y luego ser vendido en
eeuu donde tienen controles exhaustivos
de los antecedentes de este tipo de
objetos también estuvo en manos de una
galería en 2015 el galerista está ahora
bajo investigación debería ser motivo de
preocupación no lo sabemos y es muy
posible que uno de los antiguos
propietarios le haya encomendado el
gusto al galerista de barcelonés
[Música]
la policía incautó el busto el mes
pasado y ahora se está llevando a cabo
una investigación las autoridades
esperan facilitar un poco la tarea tras
lanzar una aplicación para teléfonos
inteligentes con la que se puede
averiguar todo tipo de información sobre
una obra de arte simplemente tomándole
una foto
y podemos ver que es la parte occidental
de méxico y ahora se vende en el mercado
negro según la unesco el mercado negro
de arte saqueado está valorado entre
3.000 y 15.000 millones de euros